[Music]  well you know my contract is over so  that's as far as I know Chris Evans  opening up about what he will miss most  about his role as Marvel's captain  America after Avengers infinity war Oh  everything I mean it's not just a  character's to people they experience  such good movies such wonderful memories  I miss a lot but Chris is already  embracing life after his iconic  superhero role he told et about his  character on Broadway for lobby hero  which is playing at the Hayes theater in  New York City now well everything he  sees he's uh he's not a good man you  know I sometimes play you know selfless  people who are more concerned with the  welfare of others and themselves and  that's not exactly this guy and it's you  know it's fun to explore different  avenues as an actor it's really exciting  it's really a really sweet tender moment  [Music]  [Applause]